في بولندا وبعد حاله الاستغفار القصوى على
خلفيه سقوط صاروخين على اراضيها العديد من
المسؤولين الغربيين يؤكدون بان ما حدث
سببه نظام السباقي عسكري اوكراني وتحديدا
صاروخ موجه مضاد للطائرات يعود لنظام دفاع
300 تابع للقوات الاخرانيه فمع تصاعد
التوتر الى مستويات قصوى خلال الساعات
الماضيه اكدت روسيا ان الهدف من كل ما حصل
هو اثاره صراع محل شمل الاطلسي وهنا
الشهاده
الولايات المتحده المحسوب على حادثه
الصاروخ البولندي في خطوه تدعم فكره ان
الصاروخ اطلق من الاراضي الاوكرانيه مقدرا
ضبط النفس الامريكيه حيث كشف المسؤولون
امريكيون ان القوات الاوكرانيه اطلقت
الصاروخ الذي ضرب هولندا وذلك لا اعتراض
صاروخ روسيا
يا باشا
اطلق من روسيا لا اريد تاكيد ذلك الا بعد
التحقيق الكامل لكن حسب مسار الصاروخ من
غير المرجح ان يكون اطلق من روسيا لكننا
سنرى لاحقا
رد
ت وقتها من الحدود الاوكرانيا البولنديه
وبان حطام الصاروخين اللذين سقط في بولندا
يعود لنظام الثالث
بولندا رساله من روسيا الى قمه العشرين
هذا وكان ذلك قد اعتبر ان الحادث تصعيد
كبير وتهديد للامن العالمي ويستدعي تحرك
الحلف
لقد حدث اليوم ما كنا نحذر منه لفتره
طويله لقد قلنا ان الارهاب لا يقتصر على
حدود دوله فحسب اليوم ضربت صواريخ روسيه
راضيه بولندا الدوله الحديثه التهديدات
الروسيه بات تستهدف جميع منهم في مرمى
الصواريخ الروسيه
درجه من الحذر بشان مصدر
السقط في بولندا محذره من خطر تصعيد كبير
على حد وصفها فيما اعتبر المستشار
الالماني
انه من الضروري التحقق من كيفيه حدوث هذه
الحادثه المروعه في حين دعت الصين طبعا
جميع الاطراف الى ضبط النفس اما بلجيكا
فلقد قالت وبصريح العباره على لسان وزير
الخارجياتها بان الصاروخ مصدره اوكرانيا
اما الخارجيه الاوكرانيه فلقد استنكرت
الموقف الروسي في اشاره الى ان ما حصل
يمكن ان يفتح باب حرب جديده مع حلف الناتو
غير بولندا صاحبه الشان والمعنيه بما جرى
على اراضيها بدت غير محبذه للدفاعات
اوكرانيا تجاه تحميل روسيا ما حصل
روسيا
روسيا هاجمت اوكرانيا الدفاع الجوي
والاوكراني اطلق الصواريخ لتحييد هذا
الهجوم الروسي تشير تقديرات الى انه تم
اسقاط نصف الصواريخ الروسيه
الارضيه الاوكرانيه لسوء الحظ من المحتمل
جدا ان يكون احد الصواريخ التي اطلقتها
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه قد سقط على
اراضينا والارجح انه لم يكن انفجارا
للصاروخ نفسه لكن من المحتمل لانه كان
انفجار للوقود المتبقي فيه ربما يكون
صاروخ اس 300 صنع في الاتحاد السوفيتي وهو
صاروخ قديم ولا يوجد دليل على انه اطلق من
الجانب الروسي
اذا اكثر من موقف ينفي مسؤوليه روسيا لكن
ما جرى اعاد الحديث عن تفعيل مبدا الدفاع
الجماعي لحلف الاطلسي والذي يعتبر بموجبه
الهجوم على احد اعضاء التحالف هجوما على
الجميع مما يؤدي الى بدء المشاورات حول رد
عسكريا المحتمل خصوصا وان دول عده في
المنطقه تمتلك النوع نفسه من الاسلحه
معتبره ان تحديد نوع الصاروخ لا يعني
بالضروره تحديد الجهه التي اطلقت
[موسيقى]